i figure i'll pop the top and tell uh
the wheels fall off
and tell them walking around these guys
are all laughing is this a secret sauce
everybody knows about this one
[Music]
you go on you ready yeah let's go same
time same time
same time with this one okay i like to
dive into that one is the same time as
the guest so that we start to
oh yeah now we're done now we're diving
in this is gonna be terrible i know it
immediately yeah immediately immediate
right there
there's a real tear rotted together
we'll rally through this one
oh god dude oh my goodness dude tough
one
oh it's a laugh that's okay though
because it's not okay i literally
didn't even listen hear your question
it's so hot
uh oh my god what is happening to me
um right now it's just me and you
[ __ ]
there's nothing else i see i'm like
[ __ ] blacked out
it's that part of the trip you know yes
exactly truly this is the part where
you're like
okay okay i'm in this now how you
feeling
gotta be honest with you pal i've been
you know people at home are all like oh
you can't send it to celebrity sauces
they won't
sauce the wings right what i've noticed
though is everybody's just dumping
the sauce on their wings gotta get a
good dab on there don't be a [ __ ]
baby this one's for aegis alba
this is not okay oh god
i'm feeling like a stationary store
like cleaning products maybe it tastes
like a yak's ass
on fire oh my god i can't even [ __ ]
think sean
oh it just got so [ __ ] real
it's just draining out my nose is that
normal
is that how totally normal my nose is
running and i'm heating up from inside
oh oh my god
oh my god oh my gosh my
tongue's about to fall out oh my gosh
remember you're in the comfort of your
own home uh
you were so composed did you really have
that
i don't want to panic you but but listen
i can't feel my tongue
i feel like a sponge that is uh slowly
being squeezed
you're hiccuping i'll make a beat
i'm not [ __ ] around i'm not trying to
be fighting [ __ ] is the bump
jeez the ball i don't have any good
reason to eat that
everybody who comes on the show has
horrible things to say about that sauce
really
[Music]
have you heard the news hot one's not
good honey it's honey infused with
pepper x
the best of two worlds everybody
honey now nugget nugget honey honey
honey honey nugget nugget honey honey
hot ones nugget honey get yours today
and see what all the buzz is about
only at heatness.com
[Music]
to be no to be
or not to be now on heatness.com
it's how
oh i'm a bee